we make way for the quarterback of the
chargers he's justin herbert back on the
program
how's life first off thanks for having
me and
um you know it's gone by pretty fast but
uh it's been a lot of fun so far
now last time i talked to you i was
talking about the possibility of you
ending up with the chargers
and you remember that conversation you
kind of shook me off
i was wide open and you uh you went
through your progressions and you went
to another receiver there
you got to listen to me i know uh in
hindsight
[Laughter]
glad things worked out though yeah yeah
um how
much time did you have to prepare for
that first start
like actual minutes when you heard that
tyrod taylor had
uh been injured by the team doctor and
then you're getting ready to face the
chiefs
less than a minute um i was i was
walking down the sideline ready to cheer
on the
offense because i knew we were getting
the ball to start the game i was saying
let's go offense let's go offense
coach lin walks up to me and says justin
you're in
focus up now and i was looking around
and
just i really couldn't believe it and
then
out of nowhere coach coach hamilton and
coach steich and the offensive
coordinator and quarterbacks coach
they're there too and i'm thinking oh
this is really real i'm really
about to kill him and uh but i wondered
if it was better though justin
if i said you had 24 hours to prepare
as opposed to one minute
yeah there were both positives and
negatives about it
um not having to worry and not having to
think about it was great
just going out there and playing
football was awesome but uh i would have
loved to have gotten some more
team reps that week of practice and so i
didn't really get a whole lot of
um rep the br the the plays that we were
going with and so
um having having had those during the
week i think that would have been a
little bit better
did you talk to my homes after the game
got to talk to him and
uh you know he shared some thoughts and
uh it was really cool to meet him
because if you're the backup you don't
get to meet mahomes but as the starter
it feels like that's your the door is
open that you're allowed to walk over to
mahomes or aaron rodgers or tom brady or
drew brees
right yeah i i mean uh
the first game i i got to go say hi to
joe but uh that was only because i kind
of
i knew him a little bit yeah yeah it's
it's it's been an interesting
transition here because i didn't know
when you thought you were going to play
did you have any idea of when you
thought you or how much you were going
to play
like back in august no we had no idea um
coach hamilton and i we talked about
being ready for when that time comes
but we had no idea and so we just had to
prepare like like i was the starter and
quickly enough second week uh was was
pretty quick
when you come into the game do the
linemen like do they go what are you
doing
like because they're expecting tyrod
come in
did the line know that you were going to
be starting no i don't i don't think
anyone yeah
um when i stepped into huddle that's the
first time people knew
that i was going to play that's crazy
what's been the biggest challenge
because
you're making it look a lot easier than
it really is
it's all been pretty tough it's it's not
easy by any means and
um the amount of meetings and and
lifting and
things we do outside of practice is a
bunch and
um the games are so fast the the past
rushers on that
side of the ball are different than they
were in college and i think that's
definitely something i've i've had
to get used to pretty much what about
terminology
that getting the play in processing it
calling the play and then going to the
line of scrimmage
yeah it's a little different too um at
oregon we were a no huddle team and so
we'd get the signal and i'd i'd
reiterate the signal but i wouldn't
really call play in the huddle
i mean so that's kind of different with
our offense where you know i'm looking
at a wristband i get a play through the
headset
caught in the huddle and break but it's
just something i've had to practice
but just getting to the line of
scrimmage and everything that goes on
you know you see brady and rogers and
brees and these guys have been doing it
a long time
what is it that they are they're doing
that's different than or what you're
aspiring to do like when you get to the
line of scrimmage and you see that
defense
you know being able to go okay i know
what this is or they're in cover too
they're in man
uh they're gonna blitz uh are you there
yet
uh i'm probably not there yet uh but
i've for sure gotten better over the
past couple of weeks and i think there's
always room for improvement
um but i think what they do best is i
think each specific play
they realize this is what the defense is
doing we're in a good play or we're not
in a good play
let's get to a better play and so
they're able to check and do all these
things that
you know i'd love to be able to do in
the future and i'm going to keep
learning
and get better and hopefully one day be
there are you taught how to slide
i know you're a former baseball player
but i see quarterbacks who don't know
how to slide
um we haven't had sliding practice yet
but with a baseball background i better
be able to slide did you have a favorite
baseball team growing up
um it was actually the seattle mariners
oh
sorry about that
[Laughter]
i thought you'd be a yank i saw a
picture didn't you get a picture with
derek jeter
yeah that was just because you know i
was a big jeter fan okay
but but you were a pitcher not a
shortstop yeah
well i actually played shorts up until
um i hit a growth spurt and they had to
move me to
first base pitcher what uh better
uniforms chargers or the ducks
oh that's tough i don't know if i could
pick one
but but that that's part of the game
here like
um
i would say they're both different in
their ways um
i really enjoyed wearing the oregon
uniforms which one do you look faster in
oh i don't think i look faster than any
of them
have you ever had a daniel jones moment
on the field
i can't remember i would say maybe in
like
elementary school or middle school
i never had that long of runs in games
in high school or college so
i haven't been able to do that well you
had you had a couple long runs in the
rose bowl
yeah nothing uh quite like 80 90 yards
i felt bad for him but you know that
it was like he was running he was trying
to run even faster than he possibly
could
he's really fast i didn't really realize
that he broke i think 21 miles an hour
have you been what's your top end speed
have you been
registered no i think we uh in college
we got marked at like 20 something
but uh never quite broke 21. he's justin
herbert
the uh chargers quarterback joining us
here on the dan patrick show
can you tell me about this thing i
didn't know what this was a regional
softball toss when you were 11 years of
age at a track meet did you what is a
what is this softball toss at a track
meet yeah so when you're really little
we had
like these all-comers meets and you'd be
able to go out there and and just do a
bunch of events
and i don't think they had the shot put
or the javelin yet so it was the
softball throw and did you get a trophy
yeah well i actually got to go to uh
hershey pennsylvania for the national
one
so i flew across the country through the
softball three times
had a lot of fun and that was it that
was it
how many trophies do your parents have
that are yours
um i think we've we've got a pretty good
amount
i was fortunate enough to be on some
pretty good teams when i was growing up
um we had a lot of guys so it uh we were
pretty lucky
but did they put them away did you take
any with you to
uh la no i think they're all still in
the garage
um i didn't take any with me but do you
have anything in your apartment
trophy wise yeah um i've got uh
the football that i ran in uh against
kansas city the first
the first touchdown oh that's cool
that's good and uh you got any jerseys
up i mean are you in your apartment
right now
no i'm actually in a hotel because we
had to evacuate our
our house because of the fires oh no oh
well sorry about that uh you got denver
coming up have you played in snow
in a while only in my front yard um
never in a real game so
that's well good luck uh against denver
in denver and uh congrats so far
on what's been a pretty incredible uh
run for you there
in uh with the chargers thanks for uh
joining us again justin
thank you for having me all right that's
justin herbert